the age of quantum utility and the
general availability of IBM storage
Defender all on this episode of IBM Tech
now what's up y'all my name is Ian and I
am back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
to start it's very exciting to be able
to say that IBM Quantum has entered the
age of quantum utility
what do we mean by Quantum utility and
utility scale processors well our
Quantum processors can now provide
useful results to problems that
challenge the best scalable classical
methods
recently IBM Quantum and UC Berkeley
published a paper that compared an IBM
Quantum Eagle processor with error
correction to supercomputers running
state-of-the-art classical Computing
methods
each was attempting to calculate
expectation values for a condensed
matter physics problem not only did the
quantum processor provide accurate
answers but it performed better than the
scalable classical methods for certain
complex Quantum circuits
as we enter into this exciting age of
quantum utility we're making utility
scale processors available on IBM Cloud
to access with a pay-as-you-go plan
this change is part of IBM quantum's
broader plan to transform our Fleet to
consist solely of utility scale
processors starting with processors of
127 qubits or more
by ensuring our users have access only
to the highest performing systems we can
work together to push the field forward
and develop use cases in this new era of
quantum utility
to learn more check out the link in the
description of this video
next up we're proud to announce the
general availability of IBM storage
Defender which is a part of our IBM
storage for data resilience portfolio
storage Defender aims to work across the
various silos that exist in an
organization's I.T landscape to provide
a holistic view of its data security
posture it also helps you detect
sophisticated threats earlier and
orchestrate data recovery
with IBM storage Defender software
capabilities covering inventory threat
detection data protection safeguarded
copy and Recovery orchestration are
available to clients with a simple
consumption-based credit licensing how
does it work all our new storage
Defender capabilities will be available
as credits called resource units you can
can procure resource units and redeem
them against any underlying capabilities
within IBM storage Defender so you can
size the units you need based on the
capabilities you plan to consume
construct gives you more flexibility to
consume IBM storage service capabilities
and only pay for what you use
to learn more about IBM storage Defender
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now